Christina Oh Musa steps out with a new  man  [Music]  honestly a relationship is the farthest  thing from my mind right now and that's  Christina  talking to et back in March and clearly  things have changed the 33 year old  reality star was spotted hand-in-hand  with her beau in Costa Mesa California  on Friday  Christina looked smitten smiling and  showing some PDA while walking into a  restaurant for a lunch date a source  close to the HGTV star told et last week  Christina is dating Orange County  businessman Doug and it's quote new  they've been talking and seeing each  other for a couple of weeks Christina  and him recently reconnected  turns out he's a former flame the pair  dated before her marriage to flip or  flop co-star to Raquel Musa Ichi also  learned the two have known each other  for more than 10 years and Doug has met  Christina's two children Taylor and  Brayden  [Music]  you